>> Meredith Hindley: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the 18th annual Library of
Congress national book festival.
I'm Meredith Hindley.
I'm with the National
Endowment for the Humanities,
or you might better
know us as NEH.
NEH is proud to sponsor this
year's Understanding our
World Stage.
For those of you who don't
know, NEH is a small,
independent federal agency.
We fund programs in
preservation, research,
education and public programming
-- documentaries, films.
The humanities, of course, are
the reason that we're here today
because it's literature history.
It's the reason that
we all love books.
As a historian, I am
particularly excited
about this afternoon's panel,
which features Clarence Page,
Isabel Wilkerson, and Brooks
D. Simpson and conversation
about America's first great
struggle for racial equality.
Isabel Wilkerson is the author
of the Warmth of Other Suns,
an epic account of the great
migration that saw millions
of African Americans
leave the south in search
of a better life elsewhere.
The book appeared on more
than 30 Best of the Year lists
and won the National Book
Critic Circles Award.
Wilkerson also won the
Pulitzer Prize for her work
as the Chicago bureau chief
of the New York Times,
making her the first
black woman in the history
of American journalism
to win the Pulitzer Prize
and the first African American
to win for individual reporting.
She is also a recipient
of a 2000 -- yeah, right?
[ Applause ]
She's also the recipient of a
2015 national humanities medal
which is given out by NEH
in conjunction with
the White House.
Brooks D. Simpson is a
professor of Civil War studies
at Arizona State University.
He has written and edited
16 books about the Civil War
and reconstruction
including Ulysses S. Grant,
Triumph Over Adversity,
which was named a New
York Times notable book.
He has recently edited
Reconstruction Voices
from America's First Great
Struggle for Racial Equality,
for the Library of America.
The book is a compilation
of more
than 100 contemporaneous
letters, diary entries,
interviews, petitions,
testimony and newspaper
and magazine articles by the
famous and not-so-famous.
NEH helped launch the
Library of America more
than three decades ago and
this new volume continues its
tradition of documenting,
publishing,
and celebrating American voices.
Our moderator for
today is Clarence Page,
longtime columnist for the
Chicago Tribune and one
of the country's most insightful
observers of race and identity.
In 19 --
[ Laughter ]
Is that okay?
You good with that?
>> Brooks D. Simpson:
You'll take it.
>> Clarence Page:
[Inaudible] yeah.
Thank you.
>> Meredith Hindley: I can
choose some other adjective.
We're good?
Okay. All right.
All right.
>> Clarence Page: Very fine.
>> Meredith Hindley: In 1989,
Page won the Pulitzer
Prize for commentary.
His syndicated column
currently appears
in 150 newspapers
across the country.
He's also a contributor and
commentator for PBS News Hour,
Hardball with Chris Matthews,
and NPR's weekend edition.
And so with that, I'm going
to turn it over to Mr. Page.
>> Clarence Page:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Big round of applause
for our panel.
[ Applause ]
>> Clarence Page:
Thank you very much.
I've really been
looking forward to this.
This -- I view this
hour as an examination
of an underappreciated period.
We all have -- if your
upbringing was like mine,
you learned a lot
about the Civil War.
You learned about the
Civil Rights Movement.
I watched it on television
for that matter.
And that period in between,
about a century almost,
kind of gets short shrift.
We can talk about
that and the fact
that we've got two
wonderful experts here today
on examining these two periods.
Of course, Isabel Wilkerson,
as you have just heard,
her wonderful book, Warmth of
Other Suns, and Brooks Simpson,
who's done his -- well,
his latest Civil War book
and book examining created
after the Civil War,
the words of reconstruction.
This is -- in both cases, we're
talking about a period that kind
of explains so much of our
current political landscape,
our sociological landscape,
our cultural landscape.
And I can't wait to get into
it because in some ways,
certainly the story of the
Great Migration and the story
of the slavery period were
stories that had deep impact
on my family and millions
of other families
across the country.
And helps -- examining
those [inaudible] helps
to give us important insights
into where we are going.
So I am -- would like
to first talk to Isabel
about that migration period and
then to Brooks about the period
that led up to it and the
factors that led up to it,
and then get to our -- get
to your questions as well.
So I have my faithful
timekeeper here
to do what I never do,
keep track of time.
So it's a -- Isabel, I want
to say congratulations.
I'm delighted to be on
stage with you here today.
Your book in many ways
has been something
of a phenomenon among
people I know,
a lot like Roots was
back in the '70s.
Stories that help us to --
well, spur us to say, well,
what about my family story?
What about the community
that I live in?
This crosses racial lines.
You all remember how popular
Roots was, and Isabel,
you've kind of become a similar
sort of a sought after figure
for the wonderful
stories that you reveal.
And your book, of
course, focuses on the --
that period that affected
so many millions of us,
and so many of our families,
and you chose to focus
on three families in particular
to exemplify the period that --
like we say, a little
[inaudible] bet you've been
asked this a million times.
But I'd like you to
say, first of all,
why you picked those
three families.
What is so special about
them that can help the rest
of us get insight
into the period?
>> Isabel Wilkerson:
Well, thank you for that.
I'm honored to be here
on so many levels,
to be here on the
panel with you.
Also, to be here
for the second time
at the National Book
Festival for the same book.
I mean, this is --
I was here in 2011
and now I'm back here in 2018.
[ Applause ]
>> Clarence Page: That's got
to be a well-worn
copy you've got there.
>> Isabel Wilkerson: It is.
This is my version of
the book and I often say
that if this book
were human being,
it would be in high
school and dating
because it took me 15
years to write the book
and now it's taken over my
life in so many other ways.
So I'm so thrilled and honored
to be back here in Washington
where I am actually from.
This was the --
[ Applause ]
This was the receiving station
of the Great Migration for some
of the people who came
up from North Carolina,
Georgia, and Virginia.
So I am a product of the
migration to this city.
So it's very special and very
close to my heart to be here.
I chose to work on this book,
on this topic because I agree
that this is an
underappreciated,
unrecognized epic in
our country's history.
It is not something
that happened
in one year or two years.
It actually unfolded
from the time
of World War I until the 1970s.
It involved six million
African Americans
who defected the Jim
Crow south to get
to what they hoped would
be freedom in the north,
the Midwest, and west.
This means that the
majority of African Americans
that you might meet
in the cities from --
you know, from Washington up to
New York and over to Chicago,
Detroit, the Midwest and all
the way over to the West Coast,
are -- many of these
people are actually products
of the Great Migration.
I view this as a beautifully
American story because most --
many, many Americans are
the product of migration
from across the Atlantic Ocean,
from across the Pacific Ocean,
from across the Rio Grande.
It's part of what
-- it's often viewed
as being an American often
means for many people,
other than the Natives who
were already here, was --
would be to be the descendent
of people who did part
of what these people did, who
left everything in order to set
out for what they hoped
would be a better life.
The difference here is that this
Great Migration was the only
time in our country's history
that American citizens had
to leave the land of their
birth and to set out for places
within the borders of
their own country in order
to be recognized as citizens.
In other words, this is the only
time in our country's history,
these people are the only ones
who had to act like immigrants
in order to be recognized
as citizens.
And that's what makes the
Great Migration singular in all
of the ways that we view
migration and immigration
in the current time,
people coming
from outside of the country.
I also view -- when you
think of the Great Migration,
you often can think of it
as this was the tremendous
advance guard that led
to the Civil Rights Movement.
This was the time from the start
of the 20th century
throughout much
of the 20th century was
essentially the effort
of African Americans to
pursue freedom by voting
with their bodies to get to
what they hoped would be a freer
place outside of the place
to which they were born.
And then also the goal of
this was to connect all of us
to what was the unfoldment of
what happened in the cities
as a result of their arrival.
This meant redlining and
restrictive covenants.
These are the measures that
were enacted as a result
of the Great Migration of
people coming to these cities.
So they were fleeing one
form of repression only
to find a different kind
of hostility once they
arrived in these places.
I chose to tell the story,
to answer your question,
through the lives of three
people because I wanted people
who were reading this book many,
many years after the
migration concluded,
to feel that they were in the --
on the train seats
with the people.
That they were actually at the
kitchen table with the people
as they were trying to figure
out should we go
or should we stay.
What should we do?
This was a question that many,
many African Americans, in fact,
the majority of African
Americans would have had
to consider at some
point during that time.
And that's because before
the Great Migration began,
90% of all African
Americans were in the south.
By the time that the
Great Migration ended,
nearly half had redistributed
themselves all
over the rest of the country.
And so what this meant was that
this was an unfurling of people,
this was a spreading
out of people throughout
the rest of the country.
And so that's why this
affected so many people.
But to have us to be able to
see and feel what they went
through meant to focus
in on three people.
So the three people, Ida
Mae, Brandon Gladney,
George Swanson Starling
and Robert Joseph Pershing
Foster were the three people
who each represented the three
streams of this Great Migration,
people who went up the East
Coast from Georgia, Florida,
the Carolinas, and
Virginia, here to Washington,
D.C. to Baltimore and up to
the East Coast toward New York.
Then there was the Midwest
stream, which carried people
from Mississippi, Alabama,
Tennessee and Arkansas
to Chicago, to Detroit,
to Cleveland,
and the entire Midwest.
And then there was a West Coast
stream which carried people
from Louisiana and
Texas out to California
and when they really wanted to
get away, they went to Seattle.
And when they really,
really wanted
to get away, they
went to Alaska.
That's how far they went.
And so each of them
represents those three streams.
Each of them represents
a different socioeconomic
experience from which they
were all leaving from.
They each were in --
were leaving for different
precipitating reasons
and they also were beautifully
imperfect and they were clear
to me about their -- willing to
talk about their imperfections
in their decision making.
And that's how I
settled on the three
to make this come
alive for people.
>> Clarence Page: Well,
you're a terrific storyteller
and you also -- I just heard
a little applause over there.
And also certainly -- well,
yourself and your family were,
in many ways, products
of the migration.
Am I right?
>> Isabel Wilkerson: Yes.
Yes. My mother was
from Rome, Georgia.
[ Laughter ]
And my father was from
Petersburg, Virginia
and they migrated
during different years --
actually, different decades
searching for something better
and they met here,
married, and here I am.
This is a universal story
for most Americans anyway,
but particularly for
African Americans.
It's beautifully
predictable when you go
to a particular city,
such as Detroit,
and you see that Aretha
Franklin, for example,
her family was a product
of the Great Migration,
as were pretty much
everybody who were part --
who was part of Motown.
And her father was from -- was
a sharecropper in Mississippi.
He migrated to Memphis,
the on to Detroit.
And so this is just the
universal experience
of what we view as urban African
Americans in the north, Midwest,
and west, was the story
of the Great Migration.
That's how people got there.
>> Clarence Page: Now,
how much did the pattern
of the railroad lines
and the black press have
to do with the migration?
>> Isabel Wilkerson: The
railroads were the --
were the route that --
the means, the mechanism
by which they escaped.
And so because of the railroads,
wherever the railroads
were going, you know,
the city of New Orleans, the
Illinois Central Railroad that's
of legend was what people
in Mississippi were able
to take to get to the north.
And that route, the
tracks that were set
by the Illinois Central
Railroad, determined that people
in Mississippi were going
to end up in Chicago.
And that's how that happened.
>> Clarence Page: That's how
Chicago got so many Mississippi.
>> Isabel Wilkerson: And a lot
of people say it's
Mississippi North.
>> Clarence Page: Right.
>> Isabel Wilkerson: And so
then there also became Harriett
Tubmans in so many
people's family.
I mean, I'm sure that there
are people who are descendants
of many, many migration streams
who will speak about someone
in their family who
was the first to leave
and then they brought
others behind
and that's how families got out.
>> Clarence Page: Well,
mine come up on the
Baltimore in Ohio.
The BNO line, which --
from Alabama and just dropped
folks off along [inaudible]
so I got [inaudible] from
Tennessee and right through Ohio
where I grew up and went all the
way to Detroit and where I used
to listen to Aretha
Franklin like everybody else.
>> Isabel Wilkerson: Yeah.
>> Clarence Page: But that
-- the [inaudible] line,
you spend enough time in
Chicago to be familiar
with Chicago Defender and some
of the other black press
around the country.
What role did they have in
supporting the migration?
>> Isabel Wilkerson: I view
the newspapers in the north,
which we should always remember
were considered contraband
in the south.
They were not always --
you know, they're not --
they were not something that
you could just go around --
you just couldn't go
into a store and buy one.
That's where the Pullman Porters
became essential in helping
to make them possible.
They would drop them off
at a particularly designated
spot along the rail line.
And that's where people knew --
African Americans who were in
the south would know that's
where to pick them up and
then they would be, you know,
handed -- spread to
people in the south,
read at the kitchen tables.
Could not be seen out with them.
But this is what set in
motion or gave people an idea
of how they might be able
to make it in the north.
I would consider the black
press at that time to be similar
to Twitter or Facebook or way
-- and also Craigslist in terms
of ways of letting people
know, this is the information.
This is what you can do.
And many -- there were many,
many letters that were written
to the Chicago Defender,
you know, saying I am --
this is where I am
now in Alabama.
I'm in Mississippi.
Things are very hard for us.
They're heartbreaking
stories that are told
through those letters.
And they're seeking information.
How can I make a go of it?
And those articles
about what was happening
in the north were
inspirational for them
and gave them a sense
of what was possible.
So they were newspapers but
they also were mechanisms
that would give people an idea
of how they could
make it happen.
>> Clarence Page:
And there was a --
well, what happened when
they got to the north?
It wasn't all land
of milk and honey.
>> Isabel Wilkerson:
It was similar
to what happens in
any migration.
I mean, we see that today
throughout the world
where people are often --
people who are already
in a particular place
may be resistant
to those coming from
the outside.
We see that they may be cordoned
off in places that are reserved
for those who are
recent arrivals.
These people who were
leaving were not just --
they were not migrants, per say.
They were actually refugees.
They were political refugees
seeking political asylum
within the borders
of their own country.
And what occurred is we see
refugee camps in other parts
of the world, and that is
essentially what happened
in most of the cities in the
north, Midwest and west is
that they -- they were cordoned
off into segregated areas,
which were then enforced
by redlining
and restrictive covenants
which meant that these --
the people were essentially met
with resistance and
often hostility.
When they sought to leave those
spaces that had been reserved
for them, then they often
met with tremendous hostility
and resistance and
often violence.
One of the people
who experienced this
was Lorraine Hansberry
who was a product of
the Great Migration,
father from Tennessee --
father from Mississippi,
mother from Tennessee.
And they arrived -- they were
on the south side as you know
so well, and when they
sought to buy a house outside
of the designated precincts
that had been reserved
for African Americans from
the south, they were met
with a tremendous
resistance and hostility
that they actually couldn't --
were not permitted to
move into the house
that they had purchased.
And they -- a brick
that was thrown
at the family narrowly missed
Lorraine Hansberry's head.
She was seven or eight
years old at the time.
And her father had to go all
the way to the Supreme Court
to win the right to live in the
house that they had purchased.
So that was one example of
the resistance that they met.
>> Clarence Page:
You mentioned how --
what newspapers were
treated as contraband
that encouraged black
folks to move to the north.
And, Brooks, you can
respond to this too.
One irony that I know
that was that of all --
that people were trying
to escape in the south.
But after enough
of them escaped,
there became a shortage
of black folks.
And so it became
virtually criminal
to try to leave the south.
And I said, Julie, they
can't live with us,
they can't live without
us, you know?
But it seemed kind of like that.
And there was also, as I
mentioned, the reception
in the north, the 1919
Race Riots there in Chicago
and others around the
country, St. Louis others.
And they were in the time of
World War I, really that's just
after World War I we're
talking about there.
So this is a -- so how would
you rate the amount of --
well, the bad news of
the migration as far
as some families were concerned?
>> Isabel Wilkerson: Meaning?
>> Clarence Page: Well, like,
for example, the hostility
in the north as well as the --
what oppression in the south
for those who wanted to leave.
>> Isabel Wilkerson: Well, yeah.
There are lots of people who
will look at the Great Migration
and see the response to the
Great Migration as a kind
of commentary on whether
it was worth it or not.
And I think that
that should be left
to the people themselves
to determine.
Those who took -- had the
courage to leave a place
that was so repressive that
actually there were efforts
to keep them from going.
There are people who would
actually be arrested at --
on the -- at the
railroad platforms.
These were [inaudible]
free American citizens.
There were people who were
arrested in their train seats
and when there were too many
people to arrest at that --
at the time that they might
have been trying to leave,
they would actually wave
the train on through
so that the train would not
stop and then they would have
to figure out how, now,
will we get to freedom.
So there were tremendous
obstacles that they had to face.
There -- while the Chicago
Defender and the Amsterdam --
the newspapers in
New York and also
in Pittsburgh were
an inspiration,
it was up to the people to
actually make that decision.
They were the ones
that were going to have
to leave the planter that they
were said to owe money to.
They were the ones that were
going to have to figure out how
to get a ticket when the
prevailing repressive Jim Crow
regime would not allow them to
buy a ticket, make it difficult
for them to buy a ticket, make
it difficult for them to find
out what the schedule was.
I mean, there's so
many incredibly sad,
unbelievable stories of people
trying to get from one state
to another within our --
the borders of our country
within the lifespan of people
who may be alive today
that this happened.
And that for them to
make that great journey,
that great sacrifice
to show that kind
of courage and perseverance.
Remember, there was no Twitter.
I'm saying that it was like
Twitter, but there were no --
there was nobody that
they could ask for,
there was no relocation.com to
check and see exactly, you know,
where would they be able
to get a home beforehand.
So this was a tremendous
leap of faith on their part.
And the people that I had
the pleasure and honor
of speaking to, while life had
been difficult for them, they --
and experience many challenges
in the north, they also felt
that they had made
the right decision
because they themselves
made the decision.
I think that we often forget
that a lot of this had to do
with agency, which is what we're
going to be getting to in terms
of reconstruction and the
aftermath of reconstruction.
Is that this was the first time
in 246 years of enslavement,
12 generations of enslavement,
followed by 100 years or so
of a Jim Crow cast system
meant that for the --
during the Great Migration,
this was really the first time
in the country's history
that the lowest cast
people had the chance
to choose what they would do
with their God-given talents
and with their choices of
what they were going to do,
where they would live.
It was the first -- it was
the first chance that they had
to actually act upon
their agency.
And I think that that in itself
means that whatever was to come
of this, as the defender once
said, whatever was to come
of this great leap of
faith, it was the leaving
that was so important.
It was the leaving that made
this the epic that it was.
It was taking the risk
and leaving the place
that had been designated to
them, both in geographically
and in terms of the
hierarchy of the south.
People who could not vote were
now making the decision to leave
with their bodies and that was a
tremendous thing that they did.
>> Clarence Page: I want
to give Brooks the chance
to respond here in a
little different way
in that your book is a --
your latest book is a wonderful
collection of documents,
letters, essays,
editorials, news reports,
speeches from different
people to really kind
of capture what the
foundation of the great debate
that followed the Civil War.
And I -- well, you lead with
one of my favorite people,
Frederick Douglass,
who according
to the president is getting
more recognized every day.
Delighted to see that.
And the essay is ironic.
I want to know why you chose
this one and also what it's
about is -- and it's not
the first time I read it.
But it is an essay to white
folks who are questioning what
to do, what we used to call the
negro question when I was a kid.
Yeah. What is to be
done with the Negro?
And Frederick Douglass says,
"The best thing you can
do is leave us alone."
>> Brooks D. Simpson: Leave us
alone and give us a fair chance.
That's all we ask for.
We don't ask for
special privileges,
we don't ask for
great advantages.
We just want to be left alone.
And what -- you know,
when African Americans migrated
north, they actually knew
that the north was not a
land of milk and honey.
That, in fact, the attitudes
of many white northerners
had been very hostile
to African American aspirations
and the right to
vote, for example.
And that in fact it was the
decline, a war weariness,
if you will, among many white
northerners in the 1870s,
that contributed to the
collapse of reconstruction.
All Douglass wanted was, say,
let us see what we
can do on our own.
You don't need to help us,
but don't get in our way.
And, unfortunately, for African
Americans, there were lots
of people who wanted to get in
the way of defining the question
of what did freedom mean
after the American civil war?
>> Clarence Page:
And we've got some --
a marble of understatement
to say --
there was some obstructions.
How much did terrorism play
a role in reconstruction?
And I'm talking about in the
lives and the great debate.
>> Brooks D. Simpson:
I think terrorism,
white supremacist terrorism
in the American south is
fundamental to the collapse
of reconstruction and
that it was overthrown.
It didn't so much fail as it
was resisted from the beginning.
And when people talk about what
happened in the United States
on September 11th, 2001,
and I began to hear terrorism
comes from the outside.
Anyone who looks at
reconstruction sees
that terrorism, in this sense,
against African Americans,
was as American as apple pie.
Something that's starting long
before Republicans had outlined
a point of reconstruction.
There's already terrorist
activity
against African Americans
immediately after the Civil War.
And continuing on, city
of Memphis in 1866,
African American veterans
just discharged are attacked
by city officials.
In 1873, in Colfax, Louisiana,
upwards about 100 African
Americans slaughtered
in cold blood.
These are things that today's
Americans sometimes don't want
to look at because
reconstruction had both a face
of hope and opportunity
and a face of --
a very ugly face of resistance
to that hope and opportunity.
>> Clarence Page:
I've been amazed
over the years whenever
I've written
about the period I call
the lynching period really,
reconstruction period leading up
to the Great Migration and all.
How many letters I've gotten
-- well, these days, emails --
from white readers mostly
who are not angry or upset.
They are amazed and surprised
that they didn't know about this
or that they hear about lynching
but they didn't realize
how extensive it was.
>> Brooks D. Simpson: No.
I think that's one
thing that we tend
to have underplayed the degree
to which racial violence,
anti-black violence was
prevalent in the United States
in the mid-19th century,
including reconstruction.
That we also overlook the
fact that the 17th president
of the United States,
usually ranked as one
of the worst presidents,
although these things
may change over time --
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Clarence Page: It's kind of
an ongoing contest in the --
>> Brooks D. Simpson: Yes.
It is. But that --
that he was, in fact,
hostile towards African
American aspirations,
including Frederick Douglass.
Two men had an encounter
in which Johnson treated
Douglass rather badly.
And we have to remember
that between 1865 and 1869,
a staunch opponent of black
equality happened to be
in the White House and it
wouldn't be until 1869 that,
in fact, there would
be a president
who at least had
some glimmer of hope
for African American
aspirations.
>> Clarence Page:
And that was Grant.
>> Brooks D. Simpson:
That was Grant.
>> Clarence Page: And how
would you contrast for us folks
who aren't that old, how would
you contrast Johnson and Grant?
As far -- not just
their approaches,
but also how were they perceived
by African Americans
in particular?
I mean, you have an
interesting piece
that Douglass wrote about Grant.
But, anyway, I'll
let you answer.
>> Brooks D. Simpson:
But the two men --
it's interesting because the two
men did share certain things.
Ulysses S. Grant, in fact,
is the last slaveholder elected
president of the United States.
That Grant actually
owned a slave
in the 1850s [inaudible]
slaveholding family
of William Jones.
>> Clarence Page: Okay.
>> Brooks D. Simpson:
And but married
into a slaveholding
family when he lived
in St. Louis with his in-laws.
And so therefore he had --
he's the last slaveholder to be
president of the United States.
So you can always win a Jeopardy
contest by pointing that out.
But the fact of the
matter is that Grant grew
when it came to issues of race.
He said, well, African
Americans fight
for their freedom during
the American Civil War.
Became an advocate of
African Americans in uniform.
Then he began to become an
advocate of black voting.
After he began to see that
African Americans needed
to be armed with a vote in
order to protect themselves.
So, in fact, in 1868, that's
the first presidential election
in which a large number of
African Americans participate
and their popular vote gave
Grant a popular majority.
Grant would have still won
in the electoral college
had only white people voted,
but it's the 10s and hundreds of
thousands of African Americans
who vote for Grant that give
him that popular majority.
And Grant, as president,
then fights for black rights,
supervises the ratification
of the 15th amendment,
sees that as the capstone
of the repudiation
of the Dred Scott decision.
But by the mid-1870s, begins
to understand that many whites
in the United States,
north as well as south,
no longer have the heart to
fight for black freedom the way
that African Americans did.
And he talks about this.
That in this -- there's
a document in this book.
On January 13th, 1875,
Grant talks about how we
in this boasted land
of Christianity
and civilization can allow this
to happen while the miscreants
of the Colfax Massacre,
the people who committed
that massacre, go
unwhipped of justice.
And if an American president
ever put it squarely in front
of the American people
about the importance of race
and the failure to live
up to the nation's ideals,
it would be that message to
the United States Senate.
>> Clarence Page:
I was intrigued
by the parallels I began to
pick up with the politics
of those days and the
politics of today.
And the issues we mentioned.
Violence. Racial violence.
Also, voter suppression,
registration.
Who is a citizen?
Who isn't?
Who's got rights
and who doesn't?
To -- time is short,
so let me just put
to you my number one question
that I've been burning
to ask you.
Who won the Civil War?
[ Laughter ]
>> Brooks D. Simpson:
Let's put it this way.
Reconstruction defines for
Americans, white and black,
what the Civil War accomplished
for that generation.
That while people will talk
about how the reconstruction
amendments, 13th, 14th,
15th amendment, Civil Rights
Act of 1866, Civil Rights Act
of 1875, would set
up the foundation
of the second Civil
Rights Movement,
the 1940s, '50s and '60s.
The fact is that
between 1865 and 1877,
I would argue what
happens is that in order
to welcome back white
southerners,
the former Confederates into
the union, white northerners
and white southerners alike
agreed that that would come
at the expense of black freedom,
despite black assertions
to the contrary.
Blacks would not
take this passively.
They fought against this
as much as possible.
But by the 1870s, reunion
trumps racial justice.
And that's something that many,
many Americans were complicit
in that result among American
whites, both north and south.
>> Clarence Page:
It's -- yes, Isabel?
>> Isabel Wilkerson: I
believe that the experience
with Charlottesville
and all that's happened
in recent years have
been an indication
that clearly the
north won the war.
But the south won the peace.
And --
>> Clarence Page:
[Inaudible] that.
North won the war, the
south won the peace.
>> Isabel Wilkerson: And
I think that the people
of the Great Migration
essentially were African
Americans in the south who
decided to leave knew that.
They could see that
things were not going
to change in their lifetime.
Things were not going
to change anytime soon.
In fact, during that time in the
years after reconstruction ended
and there was a reclaiming
of it,
which you would be
more expert than I.
But in those -- the time
where there was no longer
a financial investment
in black bodies, that's
when lynchings began to rise
to such a level at a
certain period of time.
The first three decades
of the 20th century,
there was a lynching
every four days somewhere
on the American south.
And a lot of people, I think,
don't realize what a
lynching actually is.
It's not just someone's
been killed.
It's -- it is a ritualistic
public execution that's there
to -- that's performative
in order to send a message
to everyone in that
cast system as to
who could do what in that world.
And I think the people
in the Great Migration,
African Americans in the
south at that time recognized
that things were not going to
change and this is where they --
that's where they made
their great leap of faith
into what they hope
would be better.
I believe that they knew that
they were not looking to become,
you know, builders
of skyscrapers
and captains of industry
per say.
They were looking to be
able to live out their lives
without the repressive violence
and terror and to be able
to be whoever they were in
their mind and in their heart.
>> Clarence Page: Right.
Well, one question that comes
up is, when we're talking about,
well, Civil War in 1865, the
Great Migration, as you --
by your account, begin
around World War I.
There's -- people have
different ideas as to
when it actually began.
But I'm curious to ask you the
question of, why did it take us,
our families, the migrants,
so long to begin the Great
Migration if you will.
And you also mentioned
in the book,
you make a passing mention
too, for the first generation
to be -- not to be born in
slavery, which reminds me
of South Africa where
I've also worked very --
they refer to the
Born Free Generation,
the born frees being those born
after [inaudible] so but I'd
like to ask you, why
do you think it took
so long for the migration?
>> Isabel Wilkerson: Yeah.
So these were the children
and grandchildren of people
who had -- who were enslaved
at the time of the Civil War,
and so they were also --
there was a greater disconnect
between them and the world
of enslavement and all
of the protocols
and expectations
of deference and all of that.
It was a totally new generation.
Also, of course, the
biggest issue was World War I
and the fact that the
north had been relying
on labor from Europe.
And with World War I on,
that meant that that labor was
no longer available to the north
and the north needed workers.
And so the Great
Migration began actually --
this is something that when you
see how African Americans are
often viewed, seen, and have
been treated in the times
that they've been in the north,
it doesn't make sense
when you hear this.
But the first arrivals
were actually invited here.
It was a northern industry
that went north and began
to recruit African
Americans as workers in --
to come and work in the
factories and the steel mills
and the railroads and
all of that in the north.
And so that meant that the first
arrivals were actually invited
here in spite of the
resistance, hostility
and actually the
mechanisms that were used
to restrict them upon arrival.
But that meant that they were --
they came because
they came to work.
They came -- they
had an opportunity.
They could see that there was
a way that they could take care
of their families, and that's
what began this great wave
of people.
>> Brooks D. Simpson: And at
the same time, what you got
at that moment is the rise
in American historiography,
the so-called Dunning School
which condemned reconstructions
of failure of the election
of the first southerner
since the Civil War to the
presidency, Woodrow Wilson,
and the 50th anniversary of the
end of the American Civil War.
Wilson speaking Gettysburg
at 1913 and the like,
that this became we then
[inaudible] this point
to call this the Brothers War,
the [inaudible] between
brothers.
And African Americans were
getting taken out of the picture
of what happened during
the American Civil War.
Later on, people would
be very surprised to hear
that nearly 200,000 African
Americans served in the armies
of the United States
during the war.
And, in fact, when we
talk about the union
versus the confederacy,
we were freaked out.
The confederacy fights war
against the United
States of America.
The man responsible
for the death
of more United States
military personnel
than any other is Robert E. Lee.
And we ought to remember
that's one of the reasons
that Arlington is established.
[ Applause ]
>> Isabel Wilkerson: That's a --
>> Clarence Page:
You're a brave man to say
that so close to Virginia here.
>> Brooks D. Simpson: I
just walk across the bridge.
I'm a UVA boy so I [inaudible]
before from Charlottesville.
>> Clarence Page:
You're okay then.
When I came here from
the land of Lincoln,
I had to cover Doug
Wilder's campaign.
In fact, I was greeted by a
couple of Virginians who said,
you know how many people it
takes to change a flat tire?
How many UVA students it
takes to change the flat tire?
And the answer was one
to get the new tire,
one to get the beer,
and three to reminisce
about how beautiful
the old tire was.
>> Brooks D. Simpson:
Absolutely.
>> Clarence Page: So since
[inaudible] but I was --
oh, by the way, is that
two minutes to questions
or two minutes to the end?
>> Two minutes to the end.
>> Clarence Page: To the end.
Oh my Lord.
It's -- this is slipping
ahead too ahead.
I was -- well, let me ask --
I just forgot the next
question I was going to ask.
It was a real doozy too.
[Inaudible] now.
Let me just jump to Martin
Luther King's question
which he raised in the
last year of his life.
Where do we go from here?
And I'll let -- since you
spoke last here, Brooks,
let me ask you Isabel, we
talk about the parallels
with the politics today
of what was going on back
in reconstruction time
and debate being similar.
What do you see in our
knowledge of reconstruction
and Great Migration
that could help
to inform our decisions
about the future?
>> Isabel Wilkerson:
What a question.
And we've got, what?
30 seconds.
I've just used up 10 of them.
>> Clarence Page: You never
worked in television, did you?
>> Isabel Wilkerson: In
the short time that I have
to say anything, I would
just say that the --
when people do read the book
that I've written, and it's been
out a while now, the thing
that I hear over and over
and over again from all
backgrounds is I had no idea.
And I think it's time for
people to get an idea.
I think it's time for
[ Applause ]
Yeah. Reacquaint
ourselves with our country.
If we didn't know it before,
we need to know it now.
>> Brooks D. Simpson: Well,
I've always thought watching,
the very interesting thing is
to go to the Jefferson Memorial.
We were told that all men are
created equal, and then you walk
out in front of the memorial,
and you look at Dr. King
or [inaudible] saying,
"Show me."
>> Clarence Page:
Well put [inaudible].
Boy, it's hard to -- yes, the
little sign says wrap it up,
and it's hard to -- my wife
wants to borrow that from you.
But [inaudible] right
down the road here.
But let me say, this
is indeed --
you've [inaudible] our appetites
today I hope because there is
so much that we don't know.
You -- one of my
questions to you was going
to be what do we get wrong,
but you mentioned how most
people get the Civil War history
and reconstruction
history wrong.
And we really need
to know a lot.
And I think if we wonder why,
just look at the great
decisions being made right here
in Washington these
days about our future.
Look to the leaders
who know something
about history and
those who don't.
I'm not going to name any names
but I'm sure Frederick Douglass
would be happy to advise them.
With that in mind, I want to
thank the Library of Congress,
the National Humanities,
the National Endowment
of the Humanities for giving
me this opportunity and we --
and these authors will be
available for autographs
and books later on in the day.
Thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]